elie semoun l'olympia quelques en dvd et
en vhf et là messieurs
ça le faire après voilà c'est
impressionnant et c'est impressionnant
c'est de la merde voilà dans quel bébé
dé la vhs alors il ya un autre arrêt lit
où nous ne doutons pas que vous êtes ces
leviers bien tous et le cinéma
vous prenez un tel plaisir incarner les
personnages comme ça quand on vous voit
sur scène chez vous voir au bataclan
c'est formidable vivez les personnages
il faudrait que les réalisateurs arrive
à oublier ça vous imaginez c'est
différent c'est difficile j'entendais il
n'ya pas longtemps la charlotte de
turckheim a été invitée chez
marc-olivier chez enfin dans une
émission et qui disait c'est difficile
quand on a une forte personnalité
artistique que les les metteurs en scène
fantasme sur vous c'est un peu compliqué
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à se dire
que l'on est comédien enfin vous faudra
un rôle comme coluche dans tchao pantin
où elle même dans l'ain d'amérique un
rôle sérieux en relevant amati quoi pas
oui pourquoi pas un rôle
alors pour le moment effectivement on
choisit systématiquement josé garcia
bruno solo ça vous ça vous emmerde moi
je trouve que josé garcia bruno seconds
sont des excellents comédiens et les
bons amis et je trouve que c'est
vraiment mérité quoi ya pas de problème
mais j'ai pas de jets pas de frustration
j'ai une petite frustration mais j'ai
pas d'aigreur suis pas à la rue quoi
enfin ça va quoi je travaille bien gelé
en général les salles sont pleines et
tout va bien
1 simplement c'est vrai que j'aimerais
réussir dans ce domaine là moi je crois
moi je crois que vous exposeriez dans le
rôle d'un petit truand très méchant oui
dans une petite teigne toi petite
famille c'est vraiment top
il faut pas lui tourner donc pas ce que
c'est et c'est vite parti c'est ça mais
les joutes sur un petit peu de terrain
alors dans votre dvd lycée moon à
l'olympia il ya un bonus en deux parties
or le première partie c'est trois villes
en province
m montpellier gex ouais donc on vous
voit en tournée signer des autographes
dans la voiture mais pas de chauffeur
non j'aime bien conduire se disent
j'aime bien conduire ça vous choquerait
d'avoir un chauffeur
ouais j'aime pas trop l'idée d'être
servi par quelqu'un je n'aime pas ça
mais je le dis d'ailleurs même quand je
prends un taxi
ça me gêne pour le nec non mais non
monsieur vous me faire me gêne quand je
vais dans un de thalasso tout ça j'ai
besoin il faut que je parle fit une
anciennement que je fasse l'avant avec
mc laren la partie et la deuxième partie
ça s'appelle les yeux dans semoun et on
voit votre votre premier soir à
l'olympia
ah oui avec la visite de lionel jospin
et de sylviane mesdames messieurs
magnéto serge
suite
c'est un peu qu'ils m'ont dit oui a
jamais été aussi crouler que derrière
anthony floch
je pleurais parce que c'est un nom très
bon truc la rouerie si l'enfance j'ai
pas dit ça c'est un truc elle tempère
cette wii du tulle où deux rands et fait
donc maintenant lourd ses fins pierre et
vous allez bien rythmé vêtements a été
touché c'était vachement à l'humour et
notre santé qui a un sens et c'est ce
qui fait le plus rire
le mec je spa c'est la dame pipi canton
des fleuves qu'aujourd'hui c'est à 100 c
est d'ailleurs je voudrais le remercier
d'avoir accepté d'être dans le bonheur
que je les appelais quand même pour lui
demander parce que il est venu me voir
c'était je suis pas un mois après sa
défaite un peu moins que ça ait un donc
je vais dit est-ce que vous acceptez
d'être dans le bonus il m'a dit mais oui
comme vous m'avez soutenu pour ma
campagne
voilà non faille et moi j'aime bien je
sais vous avez déclaré jospin il a su
partir avec panache
mais bon vous pensez sérieusement qu'il
est parti avec ma nage qui lui parti
sans laisser de l'âge avec panache et on
va dire ça comme ça au sujet de lionel
jospin vous avez déclaré lionel merci
d'avoir travaillé pour la france avec
autant de droiture et d'honnêteté et
j'espère en temps ironise quel type
portent leurs traductions et j'espère
lionel pour vous que votre future vie de
pas politique soit aussi brillante que
votre vie d'homme politique
j'aime bien c'est l'être humain qui me
plaît sme
vous pensez que jospin laissera dans
l'histoire le souvenir d'un mendès
france ou un léon blum
c'est à dire des talents gâchés
heureusement il reste delanoë votre ami
de dano et comment il va déjà mieux well
as mais il est un peu fatigué mais c'est
normal intérêt tient un couteau dans le
ventre
ça va avec je donne hélas oui ça va
ouais ouais